[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein kleines basic video
und zwar weil sie eine buttercreme
machen eine service-bank buttercreme im
prinzip schmeckt genauso wie die
italienische buttercreme aber die
zubereitung ist etwas anders etwas
einfacher weil man einfach auch ohne
thermometer arbeiten kann und eine
buttercreme mit pc finde ich immer total
lecker die sind zum einen nicht so süß
schmecken nicht nach eiweiß und sie
schmecken auch nicht schwer nach butt
habt man kann sie ganz toll
aromatisieren mit früchten mit likör mit
kaffee mit schokolade oder damit ganz
ganz vielen anderen aromen und die
passenden wirklich perfekt in jede torte
und vor allem ist die buttercreme auch
von dort auch gleich das heißt ich kann
sie unter eine von dort decke auch
streichen
ich sage euch jetzt mal die basic
zutaten und sag euch dann übrigens ab
wandeln kann
ich verwende 85 gramm eiweiß 150 gramm
zucker eine prise salz 250 gramm sehr
weiche butter und hier habe ich noch
puderzucker dafür wende ich 60
wer eine küchenmaschine mit hitze
funktionen besitzt kann die bg masse
auch dahin zu bereiten
dafür einfach 60 grad einstellen fünf
bis sieben minuten lang erhitzen und
später die hitze wieder wegnehmen und
kaltstellen lassen so spart man sich
natürlich auch ein bisschen arbeit und
so sollte es jetzt aussehen also schön
glänzen und richtig schön fest und vor
allem schöne spitze und so kann ich die
masse jetzt mit der butter vermischen
wie ich dies natürlich beim arbeiten mit
eiweiß das pasteurisiert wird also
erwärmt wird damit die keime einfach
abgetötet werden
dafür gebe ich selbst in eine
metallschüssel hier rein da kommt der
zucker mit dazu und die prise salz und
jetzt werde ich es rühren und während
dem rühren hier über dem heißen
wasserbad erhitzen für etwa fünf bis
sieben minuten und zwar weiß ich dass
die richtige temperatur erreicht ist
wenn ich dann mit dem finger rein gehe
und keine kristalle mehr zwischen den
fingern spüren
und da müssen jetzt nur aufpassen dass
keine frau entsteht das heißt immer
schön fleißig früheren und auch nicht so
hoch die hitze wählen
[Musik]
schießt kurz vorm herd herunter und kann
jetzt mit dem finger testen und wenn ihr
jetzt noch zuckerkristalle spürt müsste
noch weiter erhitzen und wenn nicht
könnt ihr die gremien schon
herunternehmen und dann kalt wird es
kalt spielen dauert so etwa 20 minuten
und in der zwischenzeit könnt ihr auch
gerne schon mal die butter für höhe mit
dem puderzucker und die butter muss
wirklich richtig schön weiß cremig sein
und dann erst kann ich beides verbinden
die butter ist jetzt schön weich und die
eismasse ist abgekühlt jetzt kann ich
beides verbinden also der fehler den wir
jetzt hier machen kann ist wirklich dass
das eiweiß einfach noch zu warm ist und
wenn dann die butter dazu kommt wird
sehr flüssig da müsste wirklich lange
genug hören
und jetzt gut unterheben das geht am
besten und schneebesen können doch im
prinzip mit der küchenmaschine weiter
rühren und dann habt ihr eine richtig
leckere luftige und fluchtwege butter
kleben und diese hier schmeckt jetzt
erstmal ganz neutral
ich werde sie gleich noch automatisieren
mit vanille extrakt ihr könnt der
zitronenschale dazugeben tonkabohne
espresso schnaps likör oder ihr könnt
auch früchte nehmen frische oder
tiefgefrorene und die so lange einkochen
lassen was die komplette flüssigkeit
verdunstet ist und dass dann unter heben
dann habt ihr eine frucht buttercreme
ihr könnt aber auch eine schoko
buttercreme draus machen und dafür etwas
schokolade über dem wasserbad erwärmen
oder in einer kleinen tüte und das damit
dazu geben aber auch vorher natürlich
beides gut abkühlen lassen und das
schöne an der buttercreme ist dass sie
von dort geeignet ist das heißt kann
jetzt auch von dort horde damit wirklich
ganz ganz toll einstreichen
sie ist sehr lecker man kann sich sehr
gut variieren und natürlich ist sie
super einfach in der zubereitung falls
ihr die buttercreme auch mal nachmachen
wollt dann schaut auf meinem blog vorbei
aufs ellis - blog.de da steht alles noch
mal ganz genau ich wünsche euch viel
spaß beim nachmachen und bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]
und wenn die buttercreme dann doch mal
christlich wird so wie hier ist es gar
nicht schlimm stellt sie dann einfach
über ein warmes wasserbad schlag zu
erweitern und dann wisst ihr wieder
schön geschmeidig buttercreme kann man
auch wunderbar einfrieren so hat man
immer welche auf vorrat oder auch gerade
wenn man ein bisschen zu viel gemacht
hat kann man es einfach einfrieren
später wieder auftauen und dann schön
geschmeidig schlagen
[Musik]